Okay, guten Abend. Ich bin Dr. Halil Kiyici und ich bin zuständig hier als Notarzt.
Als Diensthabender Arzt, ne?
Ja, Diensthabender Arzt. Wie heißen Sie bitte?
Ich heiße Jürgen Lausin.
Jürgen, können Sie Ihre Namen und Nachname langsam buchstabieren?
Ja, der Vorname ist Jürgen, J, Ü, also U umlaut, R, G, E, N, Jürgen.
G, E, N, ja.
Und der Familienname ist Lausin, L, A, U, S, I, E, N.
S, I, I, N.
Ja, Lausin.
Okay, alles klar.
Herr Lausin.
Herr, einmal.
Herr Lausin, okay.
Jürgen ist ein Männername.
Okay, okay. Wann sind Sie geboren?
Am 13.02.46. Ich bin also dieses Jahr 80 geworden.
13.
Zwoten, 46.
Zwoten.
Also Februar.
Februar, Zweiten, ja. Und neun, neunzehntwundert?
Sechsundvierzig.
Sechsundvierzig, okay.
Dann sehen wir schon 80 Jahre alt.
Ja, genau, nach den Kalpen.
Okay, schön. Wie groß sind Sie und wie viel wiegen Sie?
Ich bin 1,78 Meter und wiege jetzt noch 84 Kilo.
84 Kilo. Sehr gut. Und was führt Sie heute zu uns?
Ja, also mein Hausarzt hat gesagt, ich sollte mich dringend mal hier bei Ihnen vorstellen.
Ich hab, ja, also mir geht es irgendwie seit kurzer Zeit geht es mir zunehmend schlechter.
Und ich habe eigentlich schon seit mehreren Wochen jetzt so komische, so am Hals so geschwollene, geschwollene Knoten, ja.
Ich hab das gemerkt, dass mein Hemd nicht mehr zugeht, ja. Und dass es eng ist am Hals, ja.
Das tut nicht weh. Ja. Das tut mir nicht weh, aber es ist irgendwie so, man merkt, dass da was ist, ne?
Und ja, und jetzt ist das irgendwie in letzter Zeit, dass ich mich total schlapp fühle.
Ich schwitze nachts unglaublich und ja, also, dass man mit 80 nicht mehr so fit ist, ist ja eigentlich logisch, ne?
Aber ich fühle mich eben so plötzlich so schlapp und völlig ohne Kraft.
Und das Essen schmeckt mir auch überhaupt nicht. Ich habe überhaupt keinen Appetit.
Ja, und tatsächlich habe ich also auch, ich hab immer 89 Kilo gewogen und jetzt wiege ich mit einmal nur noch 84.
Also ich hab 5 Kilo abgenommen. 80, dann 84, ja. Zu viel. In einem Jahr?
Nein, in ein paar Monaten eigentlich, würde ich sagen.
Das ist ganz so, ich meine, ich hab mich doch vor zwei Monaten gewogen und da hab ich noch 89 gewogen.
80. In zwei Monaten. Ja. Verstehe.
Und dann seit wann haben Sie diese Beschwerden?
Also mit dieser, dass diese Schwellungen da sind, das ist eben jetzt so, ja, wann merkt man das?
Also man fasst sich da beim Abtrocknen oder so beim Waschen fasst man da mal hin und sagt, da ist irgendwas.
Und ja, das ist jetzt bestimmt schon sechs, acht Wochen her.
Ja, und wenn dann erstmal was ist, dann denkt man ja, ja, ist von alleine gekommen, geht auch wieder weg.
Aber ja, das ist halt immer noch da.
Okay, ja, verstehe. Sind die Schmerzen dröstlich oder langsam aufgetan?
Ich sag ja, Schmerzen hab ich gar nicht. Das ist ohne Schmerzen, das ist nur geschwollen.
Okay, Sie haben das früher gesagt.
Lasst uns sagen, nicht Schmerzen, aber Beschwerden. Die Beschwerden, plötzlich oder langsam?
Ja, das ist eigentlich, ja, ich würde sagen, das ist langsam gekommen.
Das braucht ja ein bisschen, dass man merkt, dass man nicht mehr fit ist.
Ja, man merkt das ja nicht beim ersten Tag.
Sind die Beschwerden dauerhaft oder kommen Sie?
Nein, also ich hab ja nicht jetzt mit einmal eine Phase, wo es mir total gut geht, sondern ich bin eigentlich permanent schlapp jetzt, ja.
Hatten Sie so etwas früher schon einmal davor?
Also natürlich hat man mal eine Grippe gehabt oder irgendwie sowas, ja.
Aber das ist dann ja irgendwann vorbei. Aber jetzt geht es mir eben schon so lange so schlecht, ja.
Und gibt es einen Auslöser bemerkt? Haben Sie einen Auslöser bemerkt?
Ich wüsste jetzt nicht. Eigentlich lebe ich ja natürlich schon jetzt in meinem Alter.
Da lebt man ja nicht besonders aufregend.
Aber der Alter hat ja alles seine Routine und eigentlich gibt es nichts, was mir auffällt, wo es irgendwelche Besonderheiten sind.
Ja, so macht das.
Und dann vielleicht eben das auch fragen.
Haben Sie früher schon einmal im Krankenhaus? Hatten Sie im Krankenhaus davor?
Ob ich schon mal im Krankenhaus war? Im Laufe meines Lebens war ich natürlich schon mal im Krankenhaus, ja.
Also einmal hatte ich, also ich habe immer ein bisschen Probleme mit den Bandscheiben.
Und das war einmal so schlimm, dass ich da für zwei Tage mal stationär war, weil man geguckt hat, ob da irgendwas ist.
Aber sonst also, ja, habe ich eigentlich bisher keine großen Geschichten gehabt.
Haben Sie bekannte Erkrankungen?
Ja, also ich habe ein bisschen erhöhte Blutfettwerte und deswegen nehme ich jeden Abend so Simvastatin-Tabletten ein.
Aber sonst habe ich eigentlich, na ja, und dann hatte ich einmal, das ist schon eine ganze Weile her, so ein bisschen mit dem Magen zu tun.
Und da hat mir mein Hausarzt Pantoprazol verschrieben und das nehme ich jetzt seitdem immer.
Und dann, ja, wo ich noch Probleme habe, ist mit den Augen.
Ich habe eigentlich immer so eine gereizte, solche gereizten Augen, dass ich so eine chronische Binderhautentzündung habe.
Und da nehme ich halt regelmäßig Augentropfen und damit geht es mir dann aber ganz gut.
Und haben Sie Allergien gegen Medikamente oder andere Sachen?
Es gibt eigentlich nur eine Sache, auf die ich allergisch bin, das ist auch sehr schade, weil das jetzt gerade die Jahreszeit ist.
Ich bin allergisch auf Erdbeeren. Ich darf also keine frischen Erdbeeren essen.
Als Marmelade oder so geht es aber eben oder im Eis geht auch, aber frische Erdbeeren darf ich nicht essen.
Da kriege ich also einen schrecklichen Hautausschlag. Ja, und das lässt man dann lieber sein.
Haben Sie Gelenkschmerzen?
Gelenkschmerzen? Nee, das habe ich eigentlich nicht.
Hatten Sie Fieber mit dieser Schwellungen?
Ja, also das ist mir tatsächlich auch gefallen, weil ich nachts so schwitze, habe ich mich denn jetzt mal gemessen.
Und jetzt habe ich seit einigen Tagen, habe ich immer so mal erhöhte Temperatur und manchmal auch richtig Fieber, dass ich also über 38 bin.
Über 38? Ja und sonst mal so 37,8 und 37,6 und 37,9, aber ein paar Mal war ich eben auch über 38.
Und haben Sie Hautausschlag im Gesicht?
Jetzt nicht, nein ich esse ja keine Erdbeeren.
Reagieren Sie empfindlich auf Sonne?
Auf Sonne? Naja, also ich gehe jetzt nicht mehr so in die Knall-Sonne, das soll man ja nicht, aber ich wüsste jetzt nicht, dass ich da irgendwie empfindlich reagiere.
Und haben Sie Müdigkeit oder Geschwitzverlust? Sie haben Geschwitzverlust, aber Müdigkeit auch?
Ja, das habe ich gesagt, dass ich mich so müde und schlapp fühle und so als ob so die, ja, ob so einer den Stecker gezogen hat, so fühlt sich das ein bisschen an.
Ja, ich fühle mich sehr müde.
Und auch Haarausfall auch?
Haarausfall? Naja, in meinem Alter hat man eh nicht mehr so viele Haare auf dem Kopf, aber ist mir jetzt nicht aufgefallen.
Und gibt es auch Mundgeschwüre oder?
Mundgeschwüre? Nee, habe ich eigentlich nicht.
Okay, dann habe ich das in Ordnung.
Haben Sie andere Beschwerden wie Hüsten oder Atemnot?
Nee, also wenn ich mich verschlucke, muss ich mal Hüsten, aber normalerweise jetzt so habe ich keine Hüsten.
Hatten Sie früher Ihre Laborwerte, zum Beispiel Blutwerte, gemessen lassen?
Ja, also man hat das ja festgestellt, dass ich ein bisschen erhöhte Cholesterinwerte habe.
Und ja, als ich damals mit den Magenschmerzen da war, da haben die natürlich auch danach geguckt.
Und so alle zwei oder drei Jahre macht der Hausarzt auch so einen Checkup.
Ja, und dann wird immer geguckt, aber das ist jetzt schon wieder eine Weile her.
Und wie geht es mit Schlafen? Haben Sie Schlafstörungen?
Ja, ich habe ja gesagt, ich schwitze in der Nacht so unglaublich und das macht mich natürlich wach, wenn ich dann verschwitzt bin.
Und außerdem muss ich auch so zweimal in der Nacht bestimmt auf die Toilette gehen.
Und wenn ich dann natürlich auch aufwache, weil ich verschwitzt bin, dann muss ich natürlich auch auf die Toilette gehen und umgekehrt.
Wenn ich auf die Toilette muss, merke ich dann, oh, du bist ja ganz nass geschwitzt, dann muss ich mir halt ein neues Hemd anziehen.
Und vielleicht haben Sie Probleme mit Wasserlassen oder nicht?
Ja, also eigentlich davon abgesehen, dass ich nachts eben auch auf die Toilette muss. Aber sonst habe ich da Gott sei Dank eigentlich noch keine Probleme.
Hatten Sie in diesen zwei Monaten Taubheizgefühl oder Friedbällen?
Wo sollte das sein? Nein, ich wüsste nicht, wo ich Kribbeln oder Taubheizgefühl hatte.
Oder Sehstörungen oder Doppelbilder?
Sehstörungen? Nein, das hatte ich nicht. Ich meine, meine Augen sind nicht mehr so gut.
Klar, ich trage ja eine Brille, aber mit der Brille geht gut.
Ok, verstehe. Und wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Das habe ich Ihnen doch gerade schon gesagt, dass es mir zurzeit überhaupt nicht schmeckt und dass ich auch schon 5 Kilo abgenommen habe.
Aha, und ja.
Treiben Sie regelmäßig Sport?
Nein, also das ist nun wirklich nicht meine starke Seite. Also ich versuche regelmäßig ein bisschen spazieren zu gehen.
Aber dass ich jetzt nur noch richtig viel Sport treibe, das kann ich nicht sagen. Früher ist schon lange, lange her.
Da habe ich natürlich mehr Sport gemacht, aber mit 80 Jahren muss ich das mir nicht an tun.
Verstehe.
Und Sie?
Nicht mehr, würde ich mal sagen. Ja, also ich habe viele Jahre geraucht, aber ich habe das schon aufgegeben, ja, als ich so in Ruhestand gegangen bin.
Also vor 18 Jahren habe ich das Rauchen aufgehört.
Vor 18 Jahren. Und trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, also ein Glas Wein abends. Das trinke ich sehr gerne und das trinke ich auch ziemlich regelmäßig, ja.
Bitte nehmen Sie nicht diese Frage persönlich, aber ich muss das fragen.
Konsumieren Sie Drogen?
Nee, solange Sie ein Glas Wein und was weiß ich, meine Tabletten nicht als Drogen betrachten. Nee, nee, sowas mache ich nicht.
Würden Sie schon einmal operiert?
Nein, ich bin tatsächlich bisher heim davongekommen. Also wie gesagt, diese Wandscheibengeschichte, da habe ich nur die Schmerzen.
Aber das war seinerzeit so, dass das mit Krankengymnastik und so wieder in Ordnung gegangen ist und dann musste ich nicht operiert werden.
Verstehe. Nehmen Sie regelmäßig Medikamente ein?
Naja, also ich nehme das Statin gegen die Blutfettwerte und dann nehme ich halt das Pantoprazol für den Magen.
Und wenn die Rückenschmerzen zu doll werden, dann nehme ich Ibuprofen ein.
Und dann muss ich eben noch regelmäßig diese Augentropfen nehmen.
Seit wann haben Sie diese Rückenschmerzen?
Die Rückenschmerzen? Also bestimmt schon 30 Jahre.
30.
Aber also meistens sind die erträglich, aber je nachdem, wenn man mal irgendwie eine blöde Bewegung macht oder auch wenn es mal kalt gewesen ist oder so, das kann der Rücken auch nicht so gut haben.
Verstehe. Und haben Sie Juckreis?
Juckreis? Nö.
Okay. Ich glaube, ich habe mit meinem Faden fertig.
Dann können wir jetzt dieses Gespräch beenden und dann wieder machen mit den anderen Untersuchungen,
körperlichen Untersuchungen und die anderen Untersuchungen.
Ja, was für Untersuchungen machen Sie denn jetzt?
Ich mache jetzt ein Blut-Labor-Werte-Controllieren.
Zuerst mache ich natürlich eine körperliche Untersuchung.
Danach diese Laborwerte.
Dann mache ich was? Was soll ich machen? Dann spreche ich mit meinem Oberarzt.
Okay, gut. Dann gucken wir, wie es weitergeht. Alles klar.
Herr Lausen, darf ich eine Frage stellen?
Ja.
Haben Sie in den letzten sechs Monaten im Ausland und erinnern Sie sich an einen Insektenstich oder einen Inseksstich?
Also ich war nicht im Ausland und ich habe wohl immer mal im Sommer Mückenstiche, aber jetzt eine Zecke hatte ich nicht in letzter Zeit.
Danke.
Möchte noch jemand irgendwas fragen?
Ja klar.
Wie groß sind die Geschirrwürmler in Knoten?
Ich habe die Sprache nicht ganz schlecht verstanden. Kannst du das bitte noch einmal wiederholen?
Ja, wie groß sind die?
Klein oder groß?
Also da ist natürlich etwas, was sonst nicht da ist. Insofern ist es größer.
Das sind vielleicht Knubbel, die vielleicht drei Zentimeter groß sind oder dick sind, würde ich sagen.
Sind die hart oder weit?
Ganz hart sind die nicht.
Haben Sie an anderen Körperteilen Geschwürmler in Knoten bemerkt?
Ja, also ich habe das schon bemerkt beim Abtrocknen, dass es unter dem Arm so ein bisschen weh tut. Da ist auch etwas geschwollen.
Guten Abend Frau Oberersten.
Guten Abend.
Ich möchte über einen neuen Patient berichten.
Der Name des Patienten ist Jürgen Lausin, 80 Jahre alt, geboren am 2.2.1946.
Er ist 1,76 Meter groß und 4,80 Kilogramm schwer.
Er hat sich wegen ungewollten Gewissverlust und Lymphknotenschwerlungen vorgestellt.
Leidsymptomatisch bestehen seit etwa zwei Monaten schmerzlose Lymphknotenschwerlungen.
Die Lymphknoten sind beim Pasten nicht schmerzhaft.
Sobald sich der Patient über eine Zunahme des Halsumfangs berichtet.
Begleitend bestehen B-Symptomatik mit undulierendem Fieber, Schüttelfrost, Schweißausdürchen, Inappetanz und ungewolltem Gewissverlust.
Außerdem berichtet der Patient über trockenen Husten.
Aufgrund der schmerzlosen Zervikalien, Lymphadenopathie und B-Symptomatik denke ich am ersten an eine Rötschgen-Lymphung.
Was würde differential diagnostisch noch in Frage kommen?
Differential diagnostisch denke ich an eine non-Poetsch-Kinder-Lymphung.
Eine infektiöse Mononucleose.
Und eine tuberkulose.
Okay. Ja, okay. Gut. Ja. Und was machen Sie diagnostisch mit dem Patienten?
Diagnostisch mache ich zuerst eine körperliche Untersuchung.
Worauf achten Sie bei der körperlichen Untersuchung?
Ich mache diese körperliche Untersuchung mit komplettem Lymphknotenstatus.
Auf alle Fälle, ja.
Und Untersuchungen auf Hepatosyplenomegalie.
Ah ja, sehr gut.
Danach mache ich eine Labouruntersuchung mit großem Blutbild.
Und differential Blutbild.
Und auch Entzündungsparameter.
Ja, auf alle Fälle, ja, genau.
Lactaterehydrogenase, Leber- und Nierenwärten, Elektrolyten.
Und Geronussparameter.
Ja.
Zusätzlich plane ich eine Sonographie der Lymphnoten.
Eine Sonographie, ja. Von wo?
Der Sonographie der Lymphnoten.
Und des Abdomens, so wie ein Röntgen-Torax.
Okay, ja, genau.
Vielleicht brauchen wir später eine Lymphnotenbiopsie mit Histologie.
Ja, sehr gut, okay.
Falls sich Ihre Diagnose bestätigt, was wäre das therapeutische Vorgehen?
Therapeutisch nehme ich in dieser Situation den Patienten stationär auf.
Und fordere ein hermato-onkologisches Prinzip an.
Natürlich, die definierte Therapie richtet sich nach Histologie und Stadium.
Zum Beispiel systemische Chemotherapie und gegebenenfalls Radiotherapie.
Sehr gut, okay.
Gut, ja, da haben wir schon praktisch alles abgedeckt, ja.
Okay, gut, ja, dann halten Sie mich auf dem Laufenden, was für Ergebnisse rausgekommen sind.
Bringt der denn irgendwelche Risikofaktoren mit?
Für Lymphomat meinen Sie?
Ja.
Risikofaktoren, vielleicht eine Infektion.
Okay, ja.
Ja, aber überhaupt nicht.
Vielleicht Epstein-Barr-Virus-Infektion kann sein.
Ja, aber macht Epstein-Barr, macht das in der Spätfolge Hodgkin-Lymphom möglicherweise?
Nicht Hodgkin-Lymphom, aber die andere Lymphomas can sein.
Ah, okay. Ah ja, okay, okay.
Gut, ja, also wie gesagt, wir gucken, was bei Ihren Ergebnissen rauskommt, ja.
Gut, dann sind wir heute sehr schnell fertig und kommen schon gleich zur Manöverkritik.
Sie haben schon gemerkt, dass wir so ein Sprechen ein bisschen Kommunikationsprobleme haben.
Sie brauchen relativ lange, um Ihre Fragen zu formulieren.
Ja, es kommen ziemlich lange Pausen. Sie suchen so ein bisschen.
Ja, das ist natürlich jetzt auch, ich glaube, es ist kein Düsseldorfer Fall, wenn ich richtig informiert bin.
Bin mir gar nicht sicher. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob es ein Düsseldorfer Fall ist.
Und es ist natürlich auch einer, der nicht ständig bedient wird.
Also den habe ich noch nicht so wahnsinnig oft gemacht.
Und ich glaube, es ist sogar ein Düsseldorfer, wenn ich jetzt überlege.
Na gut, wie auch immer.
Aber es ist nicht so ein klassischer Fall, der jetzt eine Menge eindeutiger Symptomatik bringt, sondern das ist relativ diffus, ist klar.
Aber was mir aufgefallen ist, dass sie, ja, und das hat den Patienten natürlich auch so ein bisschen ärgerlich gemacht,
dass sie oftmals Dinge gefragt haben, die er ihnen schon erzählt hat.
Ja.
Und das macht natürlich keinen guten Eindruck. Es macht beim echten Patienten keinen guten Eindruck.
Es macht auch in der Prüfung keinen guten Eindruck.
Wenn Sie nicht praktisch zugehört haben, welche Informationen der Patient Ihnen schon gegeben hat.
Wenn er also sagt, ich bin so schlapp und mein Essen schmeckt mir nicht, ich habe schon fünf Kilo abgenommen.
Und Sie fragen ihn dann, wie ist denn Ihr Appetit in letzter Zeit?
Ja, kommt es nicht so gut rüber, dann fühlt er sich nicht so richtig ernst genommen.
Ja, gut. Was mir dann aufgefallen ist, dass sie eigentlich zwei, ja, nicht komplett unwichtige Dinge,
vielleicht nicht primär wichtige, aber eben ja doch schon auch entscheidende Dinge gar nicht abgefragt haben,
nämlich die Familienanamnese. Das hat ja noch eine Kollegin nachgefragt.
Und sie haben auch überhaupt keine Sozialanamnese gemacht.
Das hat ja ein bisschen was damit zu tun, wie so jemand versorgt ist auch und wie er sozial gestellt ist,
zum Beispiel mit einer Diagnose und mit einer Krankheitsbehandlung fertig zu werden.
Ja, ist das jemand, der sich gar nicht vorstellen kann, was da auf ihn zukommt?
Oder ist das jemand, der mitdenkt? Ja, gut.
Und ist er jetzt zum Beispiel familiär abgesichert durch eine Partnerschaft?
Hat er Kinder? Haben Sie nicht gefragt? Ja, haben Sie dementsprechend auch nicht erzählt?
Ja, was Sie auch nicht erzählt haben.
Ich habe das nochmal so als kleinen Hinweis gegeben, Risikofaktoren.
Noxiananamnese haben Sie im Arzt-Arts-Gespräch völlig unter den Tisch fallen lassen, haben Sie nicht erwähnt.
Ja, das war das. Eine Winzigkeit.
Passen Sie auf bei den Zahlen. Der hat Ihnen gesagt, er ist 178 groß.
Sie haben daraus 176 gemacht. Das sind zwar nur zwei Zentimeter, aber Exaktheit ist ja gerade bei den Zahlen wichtig.
Sie haben ein bisschen Probleme, aber ich weiß, dass das für viele ganz schwierig ist, mit dem Z.
78 Kilo, 80 Jahre.
Das Z ist ein schwieriger Buchstabe für Nicht-Ruthersprachler, weiß ich.
Ja, ist so. Gut. Also das war die Zahl.
Dann war die Familienanamnese und die Sozialanamnese, die gefehlt haben.
Dann ist mir noch was aufgefallen. Sie haben den Patienten ja gefragt, ob er Husten hat.
Und da hat er eigentlich nur gesagt, wenn ich mich mal verschlucke, dann muss ich doll husten, aber sonst nicht.
Und da haben Sie dann in dem Arzt-Arzt-Gespräch gesagt, er hat trockenen Husten. Das stimmt ja eigentlich nicht.
Und Sie haben auch gesagt, dass er Schüttelfrost hat. Das hat er aber nicht gesagt.
Er hat gesagt, er schwitzt in der Nacht. Und daraufhin hat er mal Fieber gemessen.
Also es muss einem ja eigentlich schon spürbar schlecht gehen, dass man selber bei sich Fieber wisst.
Ich messe ja nicht jeden Tag meine Temperatur.
Und er hat halt gemerkt, dass er nachtgeschwitzt hat. Und da hat er gemerkt, oh ja, meine Temperatur ist ja eigentlich immer ein bisschen erhöht.
Ja, sonst hätte er das gar nicht gemerkt. Also das war nicht so ganz korrekt.
Sie haben das natürlich alles sehr schön subsummiert unter B-Symptomatik. War ja auch richtig.
B-Symptomatik ist positiv mit Tralala, also was weiß ich, Fieber, Nachtschweiß, Gewichtsverlust.
Ja, stimmt ja alles. Und Sie haben, meine ich auch, im Arzt-Arzt-Gespräch,
keine Vorerkrankungen erwähnt und keine Medikamenteneinnahme.
Das ist, meine ich, unter den Tisch gefallen.
Das heißt, Sie haben sich viel Arbeit gemacht, das alles zu erfragen, haben das aber gar nicht weitergegeben.
Und wie gesagt, zwei große Lücken im Fragesystem. Gucken Sie sich nochmal Ihren Fragebogen an.
Dass Sie den wirklich im Kopf haben und wirklich keinen Punkt vergessen.
Und machen Sie sich so weit notizen, dass Sie auf alle Fälle das, was Sie erfragt haben,
sich markieren, damit Sie das auch komplett und richtig wiedergeben.
Und zum Beispiel auch dann, wenn der Patient das an einer anderen Stelle Ihnen erzählt,
trotzdem realisieren. Ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob Sie Probleme hatten, mich akustisch inhaltlich zu verstehen.
Ob ich zu schnell geredet habe, weiß ich nicht.
Aber eigentlich, meine ich, habe ich mich in allem ziemlich eindeutig und präzise ausgedrückt,
dass das eigentlich auch nicht unter den Tisch fallen sollte.
Ja, das wäre das, was ich jetzt für die Prüfung Ihnen als Tipp geben kann.
Dass Sie sich nochmal wirklich einen akribischen Fragebogen machen, den Sie auch wirklich jederzeit abrufen können.
Und dass Sie dann anhand des Fragebogens, den Sie im Kopf haben,
wirklich auch jedes Detail aus dem Anamnese-Gespräch wiedergeben.
Natürlich waren Ihre fachlichen Sachen dann... da kann ich Ihnen nichts erzählen.
Klar, Sie machen die körperliche Untersuchung checken, die Lymphknoten machen, vor allen Dingen eben die Labour-Untersuchung.
Da brauche ich Ihnen nichts zu erzählen. Das ist natürlich alles korrekt gewesen.
Und eben auch die Lymphknoten-Untersuchung, die Pumption, die dann so als nächstes drankommt,
wenn die Blutwerte eindeutige Richtung angeben.
Gut, ja, mit vielen Lücken waren Sie ziemlich schnell, würde ich sagen.
Versuchen Sie, bis zur Prüfung das noch ein bisschen zu festigen.
Gucken Sie sich nochmal ein paar... Sie haben ja wahrscheinlich jede Menge Fallbeispiele.
Das war der erste.
Ja, aber Sie haben noch bestimmt Unterlagen von Kollegen oder so bekommen, oder?
Keine.
Okay, also normalerweise die Leute, die in Düsseldorf Prüfung machen, sitzen auf so einem Paket Düsseldorfer Fälle.
Lassen Sie sich die von Ihren Kollegen schicken.
Ja, ich passe diese Fälle, aber ich habe keine Simulation gemacht.
Ja, aber Sie haben schon viele gehört.
Ja, viele gehört, ja.
Ich weiß es deshalb, weil Ihr Hintergrundbild so auffällig ist, dass mir das jedes Mal, wenn das erscheint, sehe ich das ja.
Und ich freue mich immer, wenn ich das schöne Nordlicht sehe.